méxico rinde homenaje a los fallecidos
por el cómic 19 con motivo de la
celebración del día de muertos
andrés manuel lópez obrador inauguró
varios altares con ofrendas clásicas de
este día y anunció que el país entraría
en tres días de luto oficial por las
víctimas a partir de hoy
se inician tres días de luto nacional
dedicados a recordar
a todos nuestros difuntos
y en especial
a quienes han perdido la vida
a causa de la pandemia
del cobi 19 esta tradicional festividad
mexicana está marcada este año por la
pandemia algunos estados han prohibido o
restringido la entrada a cementerios por
lo que en el palacio nacional se
levantaron 20 ofrendas y se honró a los
pueblos originarios que también
estuvieron presentes pues es lamentable
y triste guardar de que estemos viviendo
en esta época de gran epidemia pero
bueno
el hombre tiene que estar siempre
preparado antes
situaciones siempre tiene que aprender
de esto la pandemia ha golpeado con
dureza a méxico es el décimo país con
más contagios contabilizados del mundo y
el cuarto con más muertes y la causa de
muerte por kobe 19 ya es la tercera más
habitual en el país tan sólo superada
por la diabetes y las enfermedades del
corazón